in this segment we introduce the concept
of a confidence interval the starting
point is that an estimate the value of
an estimator does not tell the whole
story one option is to also provide the
standard error of the estimator but a
more common practice is to report a
confidence interval what is that we will
introduce the notion of a confidence
interval through a story you're working
for a polling company you carry out a
poll and then you go and report to your
boss that my estimate is this particular
number and then your boss says I
appreciate the five-digit accuracy but
are your conclusions that accurate you
go back to your desk you do some more
calculations and then you tell your boss
here is a 95% confidence interval your
boss tells you that looks great but what
does that exactly mean you go back to
your textbook you pull out the
definition and you reply as follows well
a 95% confidence interval so here I am
letting alpha to be 5% a 95% confidence
interval is an interval that has the
following property that the unknown
value of the parameter that were trying
to estimate falls inside this interval
with probability at least 95% and if you
wish I could also let alpha be equal to
1% in which case I could give you a 99%
confidence interval
your boss replies no that sounds good a
95% interval sounds fine and your boss
goes out to the press holds a press
conference and reports that the true
value of the parameter lies inside this
range inside the reported confidence
interval with probability at least 95%
does the statement make sense actually
no this statement is the most common
misconception of what the confidence
interval is to see why this statement
does not make sense look at it carefully
we're talking about the probability of
something but that something does not
involve anything random 0.3 and point
fifty two are just numbers and theta is
also a number which we do not know what
it is but it is not random it is a
constant so this statement is incorrect
on a purely syntactic basis I mean the
true parameter theta either is inside
this interval or it is not but there is
nothing random here and so this
statement does not make sense instead
let us look carefully at this definition
this statement does make sense because
it involves random variables the lower
and the upper end of the confidence
interval are quantities that are
determined by the data and therefore
they're random so we do have random
variables in here and so it makes sense
to talk about probabilities to really
understand what's going on think as
follows we're dealing with a pole that
is trying to estimate some unknown value
theta you carry out the pole and you
come up with a confidence interval based
on the data you might be lucky and your
confidence interval happens to capture
the true parameter you carry the pole
one more time maybe on another day you
come up with another confidence interval
and you're again lucky and it captures
the true parameter you carry it on
another day and you come up with a
confidence interval and maybe the data
that you got were kind of skewed you
were unlucky and your confidence
interval does not capture the true
parameter having a 95% confidence
interval means that 95% of the time 95%
of the poles that you carry out will
capture
the true parameter so the world 95%
really talks about your method of
constructing confidence intervals it's a
method that 95% of the time will capture
the true parameter it is not a statement
about the actual numbers that you are
reporting on one specific pole so it is
important to keep this in mind and to
always interpret confidence intervals
the correct way so how does one come up
with confidence intervals the most
common method is based on normal
approximations as we will be seeing next